[Musica]
einstein sono visti prove per super iper
fantastica dove roma le parole bari
stage ma insomma andiamo subito e
vediamo se vincerà vitale ma se vincerò
alla vita perché in questo caso chi
riesce a uscire prima delle skype room
vincerà la challenge creative te li
ritrovi preti bucarelli
chiavetta praticamente l sky bruni
mister b non so niente ma viste beast è
uno yacht huber come noi è molto molto
famoso fa delle escape room e dei video
papabili bar bellissimi e questo gioco
di rho brooks hanno ricreato tutte le
sue este eeprom quindi con le vari con i
vari stage bellissimi quassù robles non
vedo l'ora di provarli silvio ha chiuso
rate che si inizia
abbiamo contato infatti mi sono
dimenticata di dire più abbiamo
solamente dieci minuti per uscire da
tutte le stanze
non sceglie la porta sbagliata non
cedere la stanza sbaglia barbie è un suo
grande ragazzo però mi stanno vicino
delle parole poiché dire che presto
prendi profondo premi furto aggravato
spesso il professor of e del burro
sbrigatività
[Musica]
sono state spiace catrame
buona sapeva prima la porto da
velocissimamente o che io ho preso un
martello
95 punti
chiave diamoci
una mossa
e
voi avete lasciato mi piace se non avete
costumi piaciuto subito caro vi abbiamo
fatto bene non mi stupisco ancora senza
grama basta perché qui il nome di
trattori modo possiamo adesso passiamo
in questa stanza è una 80 al contraio
guardate noi stiamo nel soffitto cioè no
siamo nel soffitto si stima nel soffitto
e nel soffitto cene soffitto
bello ci sono le prove appoggiate vedete
c'è il divano è come se fossimo al
contatto libro di natale al contrario è
bellissimo dove saranno le chiavi per
aprire la porta dice trova la chiave
ferimento mike leake per spostare gli
oggetti o che libretto cerchiamo
cerchiamo scritto siamo al 9 minuti per
attraversare tutta l'estate di
clicchiamo qualsiasi cosa velocisti ma
poi alla fine del video scriveteci
questa fra la vostra stanza per l inda
forse l'ha trovata dove doveva vedere
questo quadro di un quadro si
no
proprio la prossima tappa prima che
scada il tempo
tipo sembrava il pranzo dove siamo forse
non bisogna tornare il parkinson passato
è già passato si sono moltissimo da fare
niente questo 80 all'ora
e ora cosa si inventa qualcosa sembra un
po minecraft sin qui bisogna invece
prendere questi oggetti da dentro questa
app ho preso un bastone vedi qualcosa da
questa scatola io ho preso anche un
bastone acustica tipo bailey cup
dobbiamo costruire qualcosa forse si
tiene dove qui dove c'è il tnt
esplosivo dobbiamo far esplodere
dobbiamo far esplodere l'esplosivo
duramente dobbiamo fare qualcos'altro
pranzo pre gara ma
attenzione ci possono essere delle
l'odio la mitchell ha scritto
allora vediamo se ci sono altri oggetti
con il bastone forse bisogna prendere il
fuoco
presto punto punto dobbiamo tutti però
abbiamo la torcia adesso non lo so cosa
ho fatto sta che all'esplosivo
virtù sia presto prima che è stato il
tempo e la domenica sono qui indietro e
ora archico trenti la chiave aprì la
porta lineare
sovraprezzo e gigante perché c'è scritto
picasso picasso
per perché picasso
nonno tradotto male
costo il lucchetto per la chiave dove
dovremmo prendere la chiave
io qui ho trovato qualcosa
non ci sono ha funzionato molto simile
erano troppo lontani anche prima abbiamo
forse
è troppo stranamente libro ma allora ci
sono delle porte qui sicuramente ci sono
delle trappole dobbiamo vedere negli
occhi aperti ma non mi fa entrare altri
no ok
c'è qualcosa di strano questo secondo me
sarà l'ultima porta guarda
[Applauso]
sta saltando qua forse vuole indicarci
per questa la porta giusta no non è
questo così sono riuscito a passare
anche un socio che ci ha indicato che
assisterà la porta giusta anche se c'era
un muro di mattoni
spetta abbiamo solo quattro minuti però
ce la faremo a passare tutte le stanze
diamo vediamo tutti pulsante rosso da
studente che per me c'era una trappola
vero vediamo
maestro sulla porta lì ok
quella è la porta per uscire ma spero di
sì
fortunata caso maggio non ci posso
crederci non si caccia è tornato giganti
di votare perché abbiamo stato quattro
minuti quindi non farsi distrarre allora
ci ha stancati trovo il biglietto
trovato il biglietto
unico di cioccolato perché sa perché la
fabbrica di cioccolato può comprare lo
giu il biglietto d'oro nel barrette di
cioccolato non lo toglieremo prendendo
anch'io
è
appreso biglietto ora possiamo portare
alla prossima tutti i premi ok siamo in
un libro dio in una ripresa che succede
abbiamo qua non c'è niente qua cosa
dobbiamo trovare dobbiamo esplorare per
capire che cosa dobbiamo fare qui ok ma
dobbiamo anche sbrigarci solo grazie
saremo sopra si può salire sopra sta
provando a salire stai facendo si può
salire tollero quindi dobbiamo trovare
uno a salire una vasta scala ma dateci
qualche continua poi non so niente
vediamo se si può cliccare qualcosa
magari
vi sono vediamo a cliccare il libro è il
caso di pro ha aperto la porta
ai bisogno di piccone per rompere il
vetro
dove lo trovo il piccone il piccolo
anche sarebbe il famoso picasso sì però
se premuto non ce l'abbiamo poi il
piccolo ne dobbiamo trovarlo allora non
mi fa passare abbiamo cercato di un
teschio occhi ciechi un'area con delle
radiazioni è ottimo sì ho capito forse
dobbiamo no non facciamo in tale
possiamo tornare indietro non faremo mai
in tempo abbiamo i lunghi m sì che ce la
facciamo e qui dietro l'angolo c'è più o
meno spero io sono voi ce la faremo a
concludere le strong subito o includerlo
forse un po difficile roma no
io provo a cercarlo quando guarda
qualche parte ma che è quanto tra le
barrette di cioccolato
io sono tornato indietro l'ho appena
preso ok ho rotto il vetro il sito io
sto notando avantissimo è da temere
piccolo brigate vedo di ritornare tutto
indietro non ce la farò mai in un minuto
40 secondi proprio
proviamoci lo stesso stories dove mi
piace per portarmi fortuna conclude rea
è riuscita a finire i prof ok è come
quando al piccone in 30 secondi riuscirò
a fare qualcosa
ora 36 punti per arrivare dall'altra
parte che ansia
perché
non capisco come ho fatto e ho fatti ha
coperto
ok rifacciamo ma questa volta sappiamo
già cosa non mi parlavano arabo
velocissimi dobbiamo se stesso ad
assegnare sempre più veloci sempre più
veloce che se mi chiedeva se stessa
perché fanno per catania
ok adesso andiamo veloci sin così avremo
un sacco di minuti spero allora questo
abbiamo usato per la chiave prendiamola
subito chi ha per andiamo subito se
vendiamo bene preferita ma si può
passare qualcosa che dobbiamo fare
allora mattone
e ora mettiamo qua la torcia
creiamo sia e ma ci impiega un po più
arrivato e ho visto l'esclusione
questo anch'io tre francesi sfracellata
con le scritte no infatti aspettiamoci
sbrighiamoci gamberoni idea ma se io il
piccone lo tengo d'acqua non lo so se si
può ma perché noi diamo il premier ma
questo la porta
non credo il piccone moretta io torno
indietro riprendo libero turismo
ripetuta spesso promesso una volta
dobbiamo farcela promette di jet atto
non mi ha fatto esplodere la porta qui
perché non hai cliccato passive cliccato
sui minimi e piccoli
mi dispiace ma devo proseguire devo
riuscire a roma ci ho trovato miliardo
gravissimo
a quelli pre via ora sappiamo già che
dobbiamo prendere il libro qua e ora
abbiamo il passo
indietro adesso ce fai un metro galla va
il problema è che questo edifici lista
ce la puoi fare io sono caduto proprio
sull'ultimo via e io mi sono astrazioni
ecco perché perché passano i pezzi di
lava anche listino va beh l'hanno fatto
troppo difficile e questo
un bomb the che sembra facile ma non lo
è aiuto ragazze
concentrazione non voglio rifare tutta
vent'anni ma pensavo preferita tutta lì
mancato poco vai bravo bravo
ok mancano ancora sei sette di questi
versi piano
queste ancora più difficile questi
ultimi tre no
che ci siamo quasi
[Musica]
ieri esploso letteralmente esploso
ma io pensavo che facesse effetto
sismici
dai vincerò queste skipper un monito a
parlare è vitale fratellino saltato in
aria ok abbiamo perso croce di ma
riprendere il piccone vitale st tornati
così questa volta non farti far saltare
in aria da uno come te c'è una persona
qui che sta mettendo la bomba insieme a
me attento allontanati la figura che si
devono stare con questa volta un meno
tempo dobbiamo corriamo però quello era
l'ultimo stage avete visto che dopo la
stanza con tutta la lava c'erano tutti
quei soldi quindi fisicamente
nell'ultimo stage e quindi possiamo
farcela sì se riusciamo a passare quello
avremmo vinto la challenge ha vinto
l'escape rombo piccone si sono quasi
questa è la parte che fa venire più anzi
qui di non cadere altrimenti sarà ciacca
piano piano piano che hanno allora fate
per passare il pallino rosso va bene ma
siamo
cerchiamo di tenere l'equilibrio dove
sempre sono ai laser sto fremendo adesso
il bottone rosso che a piazzola milani
cadere al momento come prima io invece
ho l'ansia di questi vasi mi hanno
colpito lasciate un mi piace per
portarmi fortuna
ecco lo vedete ma su mister bis
cioè così fatta
fra dell'atto è veramente difficile
quella parte l'hanno fatta troppo
difficile riproviamoci brilliamo ci
vediamo se riusciamo tutti e due ad
arrivare alla stage finale nello stesso
momento speravo primo aprire la porta
qui poi vado indietro a prendere il
piccone ti raggiungo ok ragazzi siamo
tornati all'ultimo page lo odio
che si sbilancia so perché ma io non ti
vedo tu mi vedi mai che non ti vedo boom
strano non deve cadere non devo cadere
non
può essere l'ultima volta che ci provo
per te è veramente frustrante eventi che
sto in bilico subito non viene mondo
milioni allora vediamo se ce la faccio
l'ultima volta
speriamo di vitale non faccia lo
specialista più ne
abbiamo ancora si minore dire di andare
con calma torino abbiamo il tempo quindi
chiaro il piano la vita se vuoi fare
vita
dei
ragazzi
allora invece di questo già passiamo al
prossimo ottobre di mister b
ok ragazzi prossimo the beat quello
quello di prima lo odiavo troppo non
potevo riparlo di nuovo qua invece
abbiamo le case lì come detto le
caselline in cui bisogna indovinare in
quale passare il quale no perché alcune
crollano al 39 di altri giocatori dove
giornata fini solo che io non ho una
buona memoria per queste cose con di un
mini coro più dove sono passata ma
allora qua e poi io per fornire lo sto
seguendo degli altri giocatori
che lei è riuscita a passare qua qua ma
sei tu quest'aquila più già superato
l'iter eco vitale davanti a noi allora
qua davanti e e qual è il vero adesso
quale è questo
poi non riesco a capire con il prossimo
neanche io lo so devo restare che di
questo si sta rompe
non si poteva ricadere tanto tempo sul
vetro sera la fregatura è
mista comprende quindi dobbiamo pure
fare velocissimo guarda non parte
nessuno
voleva criticarti per gli altri sono
tutti liberi vi aspettano ok sono stati
fa ma io sono il primo non si capisce
però se siamo io sto seguendo queste
persone tutte tantissimi e super
divertente con tanti giocatori adesso
non devo rischiare cadere rifare tutto
daccapo per il m mastrini super avanti
io sono caduto tifo cento e travolta da
un po non fa da nessuno come lo show
attraverso un'azione sono di voleva
criticare
siamo fermi qua a risaltare ok qualcuno
si è sacrificato ed è andato qua e ora
sta andando a super avanti no ho capito
dov'è andato però nessuno vuole saltare
come facciamo azzurrognolo aspettando
l'altra persona per saltare dai qualcuno
saltino 50 50 di probabilità alla fine
va bene proviamo a barboni andata qua
ok poi
davanti perfetto forse riusciamo a
passare secondo gli altri e adesso ti
salta no non voglio rifare tutto da capo
cosa fanno finta di saltare verso la
direzione visto o no il vetro si sta per
rompere sono troppo bravi i nostri
giocatori che si sacrificano che saltano
forse ci stiamo qua se non ce la faremo
almeno questo gioco riusciremo a
vincerlo noi qualcuno porti
nessuno
perché cadremo tutto qua e va bene dai
promo genio
giusto ce n'è uno che su altro dai
adesso che stante qualcuno
decisione dentro si romperà noi prima
io andrei avanti noi si sta rompendo il
vetro o no
non lo so con quale va da quelle dritto
con la safe l'indigo dritto si ragiona
poi sinistra adesso spetta sia stato
qualcuno no era quello noti per fortuna
un mese il titolo
sinistro con sta per rompersi il vetro
sto per un berti vetro tv bravo quest
altro giocatore e adesso siamo rimasti
in pochissimi
non voglio cadere a verso le cose arriva
mancano ancora 5 6 mancavano no
speriamo che si sia qualche giocatore
che salterà perché loro hanno saltato e
ora adesso abbiamo rimasti solo in due
il 3o salterà nessuno questo è un po
rischioso sta per scadere il tempo da
lievito se lo puoi fare le mancano solo
tre
oggi promozione davanti ordinato gli
altri sono troppo lontani non posso
morire adesso vai vai vai corri e ora
no dritto o non ne manca solo uno quale
sarà tempo rimasto 1.50 no no no vabbè
quale sarà destra o sinistra non posso
sbagliare l'ultimo ragazzi non posso
sbagliare pioggia e con mister viste
laggiù
gli altri del nostro per lontani mi sa
che devi fare a prendere una decisione
no more non bisogna cadere giù
all'ultimo quale era l'ultimo che è
saltato non me lo ricordo
ti conviene sbrigarti prima di cena un
po no ragazze non posso far bene ha
detto non possa cadere adesso ovviamente
l'altra giocatrice non si sa perché sta
aspettando che saltino
qual è quello giusto però io ho paura
non so quale devo saltare perché non
voglio perdere tutto il progresso fatto
adesso
26 secondi 25 secondi sono curiosa di
vedere chi salterà all'ultimo momento
però
non so come va per un momento è
scomparso il destro wow è come se non lo
fa o qualcuno mi avesse dato un
suggerimento
stranissimo è stato super mario come la
prima che non siamo riusciti a
completare molto secondo me mi piace ora
vi lasciamo ora qualche sul lido quindi
care per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite buona
visione ciao